hi everybody Welcome to a special
holiday edition of Our advice show what
should I drew my co-pilot Rossi Russ
Matthews is here to help me answer your
juicy questions about life relationships
on the holiday season because I'm
telling you we are a better twofer yes
and if anyone needs advice this is the
time when people need it hello Lots
going on during the holidays family it's
all complicated Rossi take it away with
our first viewer submitted question
which I love because I'm like oh
somebody has a genuine question how can
we help they say my BFF and I like
snuggling and watching movies under
Christmas lights but how do I say I want
him as my boyfriend
that whole friend zone crossover thing
is always so complicated my suggestion
is if you want to say it maybe don't use
words to say it you know what I mean
see that's so much more proactive I was
going straight to like the vibe it out
and talk Rossi's right just kiss him
yeah I would say weigh the scales of if
you're afraid you're gonna lose the
French chip over it is it worth it to
you are there other fish in the seed you
only kind of like this person maybe it's
not worth it maybe you're meant to be
friends
however if you have really strong
feelings for them
you're not really being their friend
like anyway you're out there pining with
the truth you can't fully Express and
that isn't true friendship true
friendship is like everything's on the
table totally it's another question okay
I'm going to be back in my hometown
where my long time ex lives can exes
reconcile after dating others and
growing
mm-hmm I have a very strong theory about
this please I've said it to you before I
think you can reheat leftovers one time
you know what I mean so yeah yeah
because they do get gross after a while
they get gross if you keep reheating
over and over and coagulate they get
stiff and weird precisely crunchy when
they're supposed to be soft yes so I
think you know if you're interested in
an ex dip your toe in that water one
time see it but don't keep going back to
the well exactly because that is just
self-sabotage I think I'm going to end
it on your advice because I couldn't
agree more it's exactly what I would say
not even realizing that's exactly what I
would say all right next question it's
cuffing season and I'm trying to find
someone special so if there's no success
on a dating app this viewer wants to
know what are some other suggestions on
how to meet people my eyes is a tough
one because it's like I feel like
everybody in real life is like looking
around but they're really just thinking
about getting home to their apps where
they can be accepted or rejected in a
safe space You are not alone in this
dilemma I have gone out in the real
world and I never get asked out it's
like the only place I've ever been able
to find dates is on an app because you
kind of know that's what you're signed
up to do there and that structure makes
people feel Freer and it's happening
less and less in real life however what
are you into and maybe go to those
places and see if you can find a
like-minded friend well I have a theory
a lot of times we go out if you're
single with a group of friends but if
you go out with a group of friends at
the bar and you're hanging out no one
can penetrate that group you're not
going to meet anybody that way I
recommend putting on something that
makes you feel good and go out by
yourself and whether that's to a bar and
get a drink or when you go to get
groceries make sure you're wearing
something that makes you feel confident
and so you're putting that Vibe out I
just figured out why no one asked me out
in the grocery store I dress like such a
slump yeah and it's not about you what
you're wearing it's about how you're
feeling and what you're wearing right
put a little effort in yes all right we
have another question this one comes
from a viewer who says I want to post a
cute holiday photo of my boyfriend but
I'm worried about people hating on me ew
in the comments so they want to know how
do how do you respond to haters and
jealous people who try very hard to
bring you down and provoke you okay now
this one I have a strong opinion don't
don't read comments you are bound to
have a 50 50 seesaw of hell and heaven
some people will like you and it'll make
you feel so good about yourself and some
people will hate on you and you make you
feel really bad about yourself do not
post write or do anything to put out
there in the world looking for
validation or opinions just put what you
want out there with confidence just
simply turn the comments off if you want
to put it out there in the world because
you're proud of relationship do it but
don't ask for feedback stop living your
life but do not seek validation from
others that is up to you that is your
work to do all right last question
um this one I find interesting they say
this putting up a mistletoe yes or no
um Kissel toe a Kissel toe yes I love
mistletoe you do oh my God yes gross
it's cold and flu season everyone don't
kiss a stranger just because a plant
told you to no thank you that's not for
me well thank you for these questions
and Rossi I love your perspective on
things I love yours you really are the
yin to my kids yes thank you my love if
you have questions for us to answer drop
them in the comments below and make sure
to subscribe to our channel for more
because we love engaging with you guys
it means the world to us that you would
send in your questions and it's a
privilege to try and answer them happy
holidays everyone
foreign